Hey youtubers it’s Charlie this will be
my Arrow Episode 3 video.
Another big green man crashed the party last
night so I’m scrambling to catch up.
This was without a doubt the best Thea Queen
episode ever and the best Brother Sister Oliver
Thea episode ever.
I also saw a lot of you making Arrow A-Team
jokes just because of the way everything looked
in Corto Maltese.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
it yet.
Starting with Top 5 Moments.
Number 5 - Felicity’s New Job
All I could think about when the episode picked
up in the Arrow Cave was she was wearing Atom
Colors, with the Red and Blue tones.
It’s just a visual reminder that now her
attention is divided between Ray Palmer and
Team Arrow.
I’m really digging the Ray Palmer Felicity
energy so far.
It seems like they’re mostly going to play
up the more comedic aspects of both those
characters.
Which is a very quick way to win me over.
Her assistant Gerry Conway is named after
the writer that created Firestorm in the late
70s at DC Comics.
You could also view this as a teaser for Ray
Palmer and Felicity both crossing over with
The Flash show which is going to feature Firestorm.
Geoff Johns announced that Ray Palmer would
possibly move to the Flash show full time
after season 3 of Arrow and be a regular character
there.
But you can see it’s all a distraction so
that Ray Palmer can learn about OMAC.
Which the show has pulled out of the comics.
It’s a huge deal, in case you didn’t read
the comics, OMAC was created by Maxwell Lord
and Checkmate.
It’s a hyper intelligent Orbital Weapons
Platform and Spy Satellite that tracks all
the metahumans on the planet.
Off in the distance I can almost hear a Flash
Star Labs crossover coming…
In the comics, Ted Kord the Blue Beetle was
the character tied to that storyline, since
Arrow wasn’t allowed to use that character,
they’re substituting Queen Industries as
the people who built it and Ray Palmer as
the person who uncovers the secret plot.
Since they haven’t done Checkmate yet in
the Arrow Verse, I wonder if they’ll use
the Amanda Waller character and ARGUS as the
people who secretly commissioned OMAC.
Like Amanda Waller wants to track all metahumans
so she uses government funds to secretly create
a weapon of mass destruction to spy on anyone
who has super powers.
It’s a very huge teaser so I can’t wait
to see what Arrow does with it.
And based on how eager to please Ray Palmer
is, I’m wondering if he spent billions of
dollars to buy Queen Industries just to learn
about OMAC.
Like yes he wants to be a nice guy, he’s
not a dirtbag.
It’s just that he’s distracting Felicity
and everyone else with his generosity so that
he can solve the OMAC mystery.
Just put a bookmark on that, there’s a lot
more there we can talk about.
Number 4 - Diggle Versus Manhunter
Mark Shaw, the ARGUS character he went down
to get turned out to be one of the villains.
In the comics he’s a vigilante that joins
a secret organization fighting crime and goes
a little nuts before Kate Spencer becomes
Manhunter.
In the past Arrow has typically simplified
a lot of the crazier comic book things so
they fit inside the crime drama type show
they’re doing.
The Flash is the show that’s going extremely
comic book crazy powers.
What a wonderful coincidence that everything
they want just happens to be hiding in Corto
Maltese.
The island itself is very famous inside the
DC Universe.
It’s totally fictitious, it’s a place
created inside the comics.
It’s a small South American country that
used to have ties to the Soviet Union.
Now it’s just a hiding place for people
like Malcolm Merlyn and warlords doing business.
It first appeared in Frank Miller’s Dark
Knight Returns comic book.
They did mention it once on Smallville and
Arrow mentioned it once before in a Deadshot
episode during season 1.
The big twist, that secret data seemed like
a separate plot from the OMAC plot.
I don’t know if Amanda Waller is behind
OMAC, but the people trying to get the ARGUS
intel are still a mystery.
I’m hoping that ARGUS data turns into a
bigger plot, it would be cool if they did
more with HIVE on the show.
They teased them back during Season 2 and
right now they’re the only other big shadow
organization we know about aside from The
League of Assassins.
So, just remember, someone big is out to destroy
ARGUS.
Number 3 - Oliver and Thea Reunion
This was an amazing scene for both of them,
I just made this my number 3 because a few
other bigger things were also happening in
the episode.
For the first two seasons Thea hasn’t been
much of a character.
She’s really only existed inside of other
people’s stories.
Like you only see her when Oliver or Roy are
around.
So when Oliver explains that even though she
doesn’t need him, he needs her.
It’s like the show is telling us she’s
being kicked up to the big office, just like
Felicity.
The same thing was happening with Laurel,
all of the secondary female characters received
a huge promotion to A-List status.
Just from a meta standpoint, that’s a huge
deal and I’m really happy the producers
are doing that.
The brother sister moment is also an opportunity
to show Oliver is a real person.
I think he forgets that sometimes.
Last year there was that sex scene he had
with Black Canary.
It was a brief moment, when you were seeing
him with his guard down and his pants.
Just him not wearing any masks.
I still feel like he has to exert mental effort
to be the Arrow.
It’s not like Batman where Bruce Wayne is
the mask and Batman is who he really is.
Oliver is still in a limbo state where he’s
not in the public spotlight so much he has
to create a Bruce Wayne type persona and he’s
not so dark that he’s got resting Arrow
Face.
That’s just what I’m calling resting bitch
face.
If you’ve never heard of resting bitch face
it’s just when someone’s relaxed face
makes them look like they’re pissed about
something.
Number 2 - Laurel Becomes a Vigilante
One of the best teasers ever.
Wildcat will train her to fight.
Mostly street fight at first.
Wildcat is a boxer.
Even in the comics, but Arrow as a show does
a lot of parkour, so I think her training
will branch out to more MMA type stuff.
Just expect a crazy awesome training montage
scene.
Oliver got all his training montage scenes.
Now it’s everyone else’s turn.
I’m so happy with the direction they’re
taking Laurel this year.
They will be turning her into Black Canary
but I think they’ll take their time.
She has a lot of training to do.
What I’m expecting to see is a version of
what Roy went through last year.
He spent about half the season evolving into
Arsenal, then got the costume in the finale
and then spent the time in between seasons
becoming a full time side kick.
They address a lot of that in the Arrow Season
2.5 comic book.
It covers the five months or so between the
end of season 2 and the beginning of season
3.
So if Laurel goes back to kick that dude’s
ass I think she’ll still have the black
mask.
She’ll just be a better fighter.
And then maybe by the season 3 finale she’ll
have a comic book-y black canary costume.
There was a picture of her getting fitted
for a mask she posted.
They wouldn’t make a face mold for that
ski mask she wore.
So this means her black canary costume will
have some sort of full face covering.
I’m sure it will look totally badass, so
I can’t wait to see it.
and my Number 1 moment - Thea Queen Becomes
a Badass
I’m going to think of her as an amalgam
of a couple comic book characters, she doesn’t
seem evil.
So she’s not straight up Cheshire or Lady
Shiva, she does have the evil dad and she’s
a good archer so you could say there’s a
little Artemis in there but you could also
say she’s got some Mia Dearden just because
her name is Thea Dearden Queen on the show.
So take your pick, Oliver has always called
her Speedy.
But that doesn’t mean she’s joining team
Arrow as a plant for Malcolm Merlyn.
I think it will be a divided loyalty situation
where Thea still loves Oliver and cares about
Roy, but she’s aligned herself with Malcom
Merlyn, who is their enemy.
So Thea will have a lot going on this year.
What I’m most excited to see is Oliver and
Roy catching her in the act of doing something
crazy.
They did that little tease at the airport
with her reflexes.
So Oliver knows something is up.
But I think it will be a while before they
learn what she’s really been doing.
Thea will get her own secrets just like Oliver
has his.
And yes, I do think she will be engaging in
nighttime ass kicking activities, apart from
Oliver and Roy.
I would hope that by the end of the season,
everybody learns everyone’s secrets and
Thea is able to fight with Team Arrow and
Laurel for that matter.
So much stuff happened, let me know what your
favorite moment was.
While you think about that here were a couple
of funny things I noticed:
On Felicity’s computer monitor here, she
was reading an article about The Flash.
Just a little tease about next week’s Flash
episode which she is guest starring on.
That’s also the captain cold episode.
When she first walked into the office Ray
Palmer said some wacko blew up Queen Industries
Applied Sciences Division.
That was Felicity’s Idea during Season 2.
They were trying to stop Slade from using
Applied Sciences to make more Mirakuru.
She’s the wacko that blew it up.
So of course she responded with “I’m sure
they had a good reason”.
Oliver’s Improvised Bow and Arrows.
Stephen Amell did a Q&A video where he joked
about this.
Definitely one of the funnier cut away montages.
Please more moments like this.
Then the Flashback with Thea and Merlyn to
the beginning of her training.
I laughed so hard when he said he didn’t
know how to train her, so he was just going
to do it like it was done to him.
That seems like a very awkward dad thing to
say.
Like single dad trying to raise a girl.
I have no idea what I’m doing, so I’m
just going to
it the old school way.
For better or worse.
And then just jumps at her.